of course
you don't feel like doing it of course
you don't
it's hard
whatever it is could be a workout could
be a run could be starting on a project
could be doing the damn dishes
whatever it is
you don't feel like doing it
and you
rationalize and you justify and you make
excuses like uh
high priced defense attorney
trying to win the case for weakness and
boy I'll tell you what that lawyer in
your head is good
real good he's got all kinds of legalese
in his pocket
that he's gonna throw at you
he's been doing this for a long time and
I hate to tell you this that lawyer
that attorney for weakness that's in
your head is smarter and better at
debate and discourse than you could ever
hope to be
that that lawyer knows just what to say
that lawyer knows all the legal
loopholes
and definitely knows how to sway the
jury
definitely knows how to sway the jury
it's going to leave you standing there
like an idiot so how do you compete with
that
how do you compete with that
it's actually pretty simple and pretty
straightforward don't play the game
don't play the game don't argue don't
discuss don't negotiate you tell that
snake of a lawyer that's in your head to
shut up
tell them you don't want to hear it tell
them you don't need to hear it because
you are not the guilty party
you're in the right
you're on the side of
strength and stability and you don't
need
approval from this lazy lawyer
to go and do what you're supposed to do
so don't listen
to that lazy lawyer
in your head
instead
just go get to work